reviewing the idea was ratios now I
heard you got down of our sentence
rephrase the described one over here
wasn't to fight it
yeah dan you've done it good comparison
maybe it's work especially if you
weren't writing this down
and I want to add a little bit to this
can I have a little bit to this the
first thing I wanna say is it's only a
comparison between two quantities of the
same time or same time okay so for
instance I might compare my height with
your hunt okay and that would be a
length and another wing right so they're
two quantities your supply and in the
same time you could measure the
centimeters of meters whatever but it's
the same same vs. if I were to compare
say my own height to my weight does
anyone know what that's called by the
way it's a special measurement that we
take what we can pay her weight now it's
it's generally called the be mine yes
baby so we give me a strange faces like
what it stands for body mass index right
and what you do is you you're comparing
two quantities but there's not the same
time right like height is our link and
weight is its yeah it's not with which
would also be a link right right yeah
your weight is something in kilograms
okay so the units are all different so
all the same type that's important you
might want to underline that if you did
not have it in your original definition
come on I want to add what we'll see if
you've got a definition looks like this
but it says comparison between two
quantities actually so I'm gonna say two
or more most frequently we have to but
Fritz's I could compare my high and your
height and then Michael Jordan's home
okay we're gonna have three oh three I
just wanted to pick something suitably
different okay we're gonna have all
three
we could compare them and they're all
the same type a big deal okay but yes
usually we just have to now what I want
to enjoy comparison between is
comparison is when you write a ratio we
use a special symbol right what symbol
do we say if like say Michael Jordan
would say twice my height okay which
he's not but he's pretty close okay he's
pretty tall right how would I write my
height the ratio of one height to his
height as a ratio how would I write it
yeah yeah that's very good so as it is
up all right in fact maybe want to write
all of this let's say mr. Wu's height
and we're going to compare that to my
children side and then what we put in
between those is this symbol the two
dots in fact it's a colon okay so the
way I would read this is mr. Wu's
hyeon's to Michael Jordan's phone okay
so you may like to write that in that's
how I read this all okay now one of the
cool things have this is that I might
say okay well that's equal to what was I
saying he's twice my height right he's
twice my height
so one to two okay now this ratio tells
us what the relationship is between
these two things okay but that's not
actually that's not actually the ratio
so have you looked up microjoule sign is
that what you don't you okay if you tell
me I'm not good on site let it go that's
okay that's okay
just go okay now if this were true let's
just go with it
thankfully it's not true if Michael
Jordan is that tall and I've apparently
half his height right how tall does that
make me yeah now by the way how did I do
that I had no calculator and I didn't as
just was just evidence I didn't know
what that name number was for forehead
just behind re-fixed I took advantage of
a trick that I've taught you guys before
right when you got like an awkward
number like this is an awkward number
just think of it not as close to it
another it's really really close you
could work with very easily
what's a close number 200 200 soon easy
everyone there's a hot someone released
and this is just a bit smaller than so
this should be you see how I did it yeah
okay so that would be how tall I am this
is how tall like me
Shh no no no get this this is the
important idea in today's lesson right
these two things here
they're both ratios okay here's a ratio
he's a ratio but they represent the same
idea they both represent my height -
Michael Jordan's height
so these are what we call common ratios
and in fact you could write the same
ratio in an infinite number of ways you
could write a hundred to two hundred a
thousand to two thousand thinking you
could write these all different ways now
this way of working between ratios right
if you went from this well which one do
you think is a nicer way to rub write
out more concise way yeah I think ones
or twos nicer as well right it's it's as
simple as you can get it doesn't require
many numbers to actually write so we say
that this is a simplified ratio and this
one's kind of a messy one but they're
the same okay yeah big complicated now
we've done this idea of like simplified
before in fact you all did it about five
minutes ago here right we simplified and
these two fractions are really the same
fraction right so that's what we call
them equivalent fractions in fact this
skill and this skill are the same it
helps if you recognize you know this um
this ratio see both the corners it whoa
it's really just a division symbol
without the lion did you notice that if
I were to write 1/2 and then you just
don't write the white which many
countries don't actually do okay
that's that's all it means it's like 1
to 2 is the same as 1/2
some European let's get a date it was so
anyway you can you can look it up
afterwards okay but the point is just
that everything you know about this you
can apply it over here so now I'm ready
for you to write the heading which is
simplifying ratios that's all we're
gonna be focusing on today now I just
want to stay with this ratio for a
minute before we leave okay
I want to point out two things that come
back to this definition right 99 to 198
we were talking in centimeters won't we
say meters 99 centimeters to 198
centimeters okay but often we don't say
hi in terms of sediments we might say in
terms of meters yeah so for example if I
left this one is 99 cent adenine how
would I write the right here bit if I
what does it change it to meters one
point we'll put nine eight right one
point nine eight
beast now all these four things are
through another water they're all the
same right here right but look because
of the unit's if you had started from
this instead of ending with it as you
track back to simplify things you can
see you can say oh wait I want them
talking the same language right I want
them as similar together as I can and
then once they're the same units I don't
have to worry about me okay lastly if I
were to put your higher on here okay how
do you preach all I'll told you no idea
really can someone give me an estimate
seventy yeah
so we've got my height to backward on
attack if we'd wanted to we could add in
a third be right if we wanted right and
all I have to do there is put it well
okay I this is like you know 198 so this
is where we put in 170 for instance okay
so I could say this one to this one to
this one
normally we compare two ratio through
two quantities to we can compare as many
as we like okay
can some of the questions you'll
encounter they'll say hey I want to
share this stuff out I want to share it
like three people or four people and how
much does each one of them get so it's
not a crazy idea it's the same sort of
thing I can divide everything through by
whatever numbers I want so long as I do
all of them at the same time okay